il
[Musique]
c'est leur cinquième pèlerinage au
monastère de jasna gora au centre du
pays
[Musique]
cette chapelle de la vierge noire
considérée comme la capitale spirituelle
de la pologne
ils sont accueillis à bras ouverts ce
groupe d'extrême droite a appelé la
jeunesse de la grande pologne
fondée au moment de la chute du régime
communiste compte quelques milliers de
membres
leur présence ici équivaut à une
bénédiction
ce porte parole de l'organisation nous a
accordé une entrevue juste avant le
grand rassemblement nocturne
notre but c'est le bien de la pologne et
de la nation polonaise
nous voulons propager notre conception
de la nation et notre nationalisme
chrétiens
la crise des migrants et l'arrivée en
europe de centaines de milliers de
réfugiés ont apporté de l'eau au moulin
des organisations d'extrême droite de
l'eau bénie retard d'étiquetage est
immigrante pour toute attaque 2 go par
exemple achat et en tchèque sont en
chêne là dessus qu'ils veulent ouvrir
les portes à un grand nombre
d'immigrants soit de l'ukraine ou du
proche-orient agissent contre les
intérêts de la pologne et de la nation
polonaise notre tissu national risquent
de souffrir si on a de grands clubs
d'étrangers qu'il ne s'assimile rompt
pas
le 11 novembre dernier fête de
l'indépendance nationale
démonstration de force de l'extrême
droite polonais
pendant la traditionnelle marche de
l'indépendance le pays et le monde
découvre l'ampleur du mouvement à
varsovie
soixante mille personnes ont répondu à
l'appel des groupes d'extrême droite et
gel ils sont chers quand j'entends les
médias étrangers dire que les musulmans
ont peur de la pologne des polonais
qu'ils craignent de venir ici en grand
nombre franchement je suis content il
faut l'accord
les étrangers ne sont pas la seule cible
de prédilection de cette extrême droite
la jeunesse de la grande pologne fustige
tout autant les minorités sexuelles
un de vos slogans dit pas rouge pas arc
en ciel mais une pologne nationale ça
veut dire qu'un gay ne peut pas être un
vrai polonais sens montant on n'enlèvera
pas l'appartenance à la nation à
quelqu'un juste parce qu'il a dit qu'il
est gay ou lesbienne ou un autre type de
travestis mais nous nous sommes contre
ce type de comportement
je démarre en dehors du bihar a devant
le monastère de jasna gora un petit
groupe est venue protester
le programme de cette organisation
contient beaucoup d'idées homophobes
sinophobe et fasciste ce n'est pas
compatible avec le christianisme s'est
accru à portable malheureusement ces
idées sont de plus en plus présente
c'est aussi l'avis de ce politologue et
journaliste franco polonais la dernière
fois en novembre c'était choquant le les
mots d'or
les inscriptions étaient absolument
inacceptable c'était vraiment l'extrême
extrême droite à l'occident très
rarement on pourra dans le russey type
de raciste xénophobe mot d'ordre anti
européenne et cetera
mais selon lui les sondages montrent que
l'extrême droite joue un rôle marginal
entre autres au moment des élections
ce qui est vraiment inquiétant c'est son
influence sur le parti au pouvoir
l'influencent de ce petit groupuscule
est plus grand que leur potentiel
numérique électorale il ya certaines
influences sur le langage public
ils influencent aussi le parti qui
gouverne pis de monsieur kaczinsky le
parti au pouvoir ne veut pas en
organiser une autre puce kull et une
partie de la population qui acceptent ce
mot d'ordre
il préfère donc il n'y avait pas de
confrontation de la police
la police a toléré même les scènes
violentes
le nationalisme exacerbé du parti droit
et justice et de son gouvernement est
plus présent que jamais aux
commémorations de la catastrophe
aérienne qui a coûté la vie au président
polonais en 2010 elles ont eu lieu tous
les mois au cours des huit dernières
années
le frère jumeau du président et tous
ceux qui l'entourent croit toujours un
complot étranger contre la pologne et
ses institutions tant division toujours
ce dimanche
cela marche ou si ces commémorations se
sont toujours pas c'est plutôt dans le
recueillement
il en est tout autrement pour les
groupes d'extrême droite leur potentiel
de violence n'est pas à négliger
quand je dénonce uniterre dont on doit
tenir compte du fait que les polonais ne
sont pas une nation pacifiste quand nous
sentons un danger réel ni le vent pour
défendre la pologne et les polonais une
figure de style dans la bouche d'un
jeune nationaliste ou bien une menace
réelle de la part de ceux qui
considèrent la russie l'allemagne
l'ensemble l'union européenne et tous
les réfugiés comme des ennemis du peuple
polonais l'histoire le dira